from what i hear you're pretty amazing
uh in the uh fargo
you you went out and shot this thing
excited about this i loved
every fargo that's been you know what
it's [ __ ] great i watched it last
night
scared out of my mind you're happy with
your performance
yes yes i'm happy i'm also like i know
where my performance goes so
it starts off did you like i didn't you
see a great show last night
i saw a great show last night i saw a
great show
this young comic up and coming
uh you know chris did you ever take
acting lessons
did you ever say you know what man i'm a
comic but i'm gonna go
and try and bring this thing to the next
level or would that [ __ ] you up to take
acting lessons
in the last i don't know
seven years or five years it's like i
met scott rudin
and scott got me with some good people
he got me with this guy
larry moss who's like kind of the best
acting coach in the world
right i worked with him i worked with
him on top five and you know
and i actually worked with him on this a
little bit you know and so he's
instilled in me uh some
things that have helped me out that have
taken my acting up
another notch right i love it
i love it did you have to audition for
this role or do you someone calls up and
say we're thinking of you
uh i didn't audition for it and
after my special tambourine on netflix
that special made people look at me
a different way it's like oh he's a
[ __ ]
grown ass man but you know your whole
life's an audition
for something for the next part of it
you know no no fargo uh fargo premiered
last night
and so you're gonna be in a bunch of
episodes coming uh it was on fx fargo
on fx i got a whole season a whole
season you know
it starts off slow but boy when this
[ __ ] pays off
you're going to be like god like yo
fargo
you ain't seen this [ __ ] when they
called you were you excited about that
were you like yeah best [ __ ] i've ever
done oh i was very excited i couldn't
even believe it
like i got the job like a year before we
started i kept
thinking the director was gonna like
bump into chewitel at a party and be
like
don
yeah